this time of year campfires and scary
stories go hand in hand but lugging a
bunch of books out into the woods not
for me
that's why I like audible.com I can
browse countless books and download them
straight to my phone or tablet and read
them in low-light situations like Carey
by Stephen King my favorite author for a
free book download of your choice
courtesy of me please visit audible.com
slash Kris that's audible.com slash Kris
well guys the response that I have been
getting on the scary movie specials is
extremely warming to my heart I'm just
my heart is warm right now thank you
very much you guys have left some really
great comments Sam and I are very happy
with the way the skits turned out with
the way the reviews turned out as you
can see the background is still in that
zone it will be for a few more days but
I just want to say thanks very much and
I got a lot of comments people saying
they love the skits so much that they
wanted to rewatch them and so I was
thinking maybe I would just put up a
video that had all the skits in them
they're from the scary movie special
that I've released Part one and Part two
are currently up and that way if you
guys want to come back and watch the
skits whenever you want they're all in
one video I just wanted to make a video
what you guys could watch them if you
wanted to without having to skip through
to figure out where your favorite one
was I got some requests for like
singular skit videos and I thought well
I don't really want to do that but I
will make one video in which you guys
can watch them all in a row if you want
to or if you didn't feel like watching
us talk about the movies you can at
least watch the skits that we did
because we did work very hard on them
and I really hope you guys appreciate
them I'm gonna keep them here in this
video for you guys and you can watch
them whenever you want without further
ado I will stop talking enjoy this is
the story of a man and a woman that man
and woman they're about to take a
journey into the deepest darkest depths
of cinema all the way to the stuntman
zone
you
well what's your favorite scary movie
with this what are you doing tonight
honey
oh fast that's why the living how would
you watch that movie
kids these days so anyways I was saying
what's your favorite scary movie
well scary is - certainly Dragonball
Evolution you ever mention that come
again I'll cut your throat you little
bitch
like seriously is this marker Chris
no this isn't Chris this is the guy
that's gonna take a knife and spread
your insides all over your kitchen
speaking of your kitchen you shouldn't
leave your microwave door
you know marks are really known for
being Restless you happy day me my best
friend but this is give you the right to
be an asshole to me oh my god this is
such bullshit
you can cut the theatrics like it's so
1980s is Harry boys are gonna fall that
little bitch made me think of Dragonball
Evolution she's going to die yeah I
think I said it back over there brother
window can you check
hey hun
who's that
there's a guy out there
what do you think he wants I think he
wants to be in part too
you
where is she she said she'd be here
midnight exactly
corticon she tries to scare
I hate you I really hate you so where do
you forget Halloween scare my story is
it deep and dark then take you through
twists and turns into places you never
want to go
stuff scary movie night part
so how do you feel about being in
haunted woods of still Ohio yeah what
exactly would possess us to go into
these woods some stuff people left
behind I'm looking at your behind that's
what I'm doing now tell me what is this
a kids house or a swing set do you think
maybe the children sometimes still play
on the swings at night the dead children
bomp bomp ah you know what I think I
think I'd like to know
that's what I'd like to do so I'm gonna
grave their names the guy in town said
that John and Jenna were the kids that
were killed out here maybe or maybe
there's a witch out here that's going to
eat us and rip our heads off and for you
first you're the fattest that's not even
true um No
are you sure you were beautiful but
you're saying that you're not the
baddest let's just go look for that
witch yes maybe hey I think I heard
something over there yeah did you hear
something
what getting to yeah yeah that's nice
how do you suppose these things got
launched into the wood yeah those things
up there they're like in the wood
I think it was something else because
I'm agent fucking Mulder you fucking
fuck this is basically what the Blair
Witch Project is like but it's awesome
well fuckity fuck fuck I don't know
is it
you
well guys that is the end of our scary
movie special we both really appreciate
you guys watching don't we mm-hmm what's
wrong okay yeah I'm fine okay um Luzi
sorry guys we really appreciate you
watching it was really nice we had a lot
of fun talking about poor films with you
and we just want to say from both of us
thanks very much we'd love to know we
thought of our skits and we hope you
really enjoyed it and if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
on it are you sure you're alright huh
uh I guess maybe it's just too much late
okay too much light okay um all right
well okay oh God
yes my fiancee I don't know what's
happening she just stopped moving she's
not breathing I'm not sure what's going
on I'm not sure she just stopped
breathing we were seen next to each
other and she just stopped breathing I'm
not entirely sure what happened but I
was right there with her she stopped
breathing she stopped moving
he got send someone over as quickly as
possible I'm not sure if she's okay I
need you to help me out here